let's get into the Friday mailbag the
now world famous Friday mailbag
technically we got one email from
Zanzibar and now it's world famous okay
let's get right into it remember you can
email info davidpackman.com you can also
contact us via a number of other means
including Facebook Twitter sometimes
YouTube comments will be featured you
never know what you're going to have but
today we start with a message from
Facebook and it is a very important
message and that message is about
President Joe Biden and the the things
that I choose to report on and this
individual says and I'm reading this as
written I want to be clear how much do
you get from Joe Biden to say that
really how much for Miss that's Miss
information really how much for Miss
information
sir please show me the respect of
addressing me as Mrs information
misinformation is extremely inform
um for our relationship please and of
course uh this idea that we are funded
by Joe Biden or George Soros or the
trilateral commission or the Illuminati
or the uh Klaus uh Klaus Schwab Gates so
who knows anyway we're funded by people
who sign up on our website and by like
YouTube ad revenue and a few advertisers
we have there's no secret there we're
very very clear about exactly how we are
funded uh next message is from Andrew
Andrew wrote in with a suggestion saying
David try some honest journalism I Am
pro vax but no longer Pro coveted shot I
understand you have to make this
political or keep it political because
you have an audience to Pander to but
please don't mistake what you do
for authentic journalism I see you David
remember I never claimed to do
journalism I claimed to do commentary
which is what I actually do the very
disturbing lack of media literacy in
this country leads to messages like this
but more importantly
pandering on the vaccine I'm I have to
say the things I'm saying because of my
audience I've been very very clear the
first vaccines seemed to prevent
infection and transmission as the virus
mutated the vaccines became less and
less effective at preventing infection
and transmission to the point where my
understanding of the latest data is that
the newest vaccines don't prevent
infection nor transmission but they are
still effective at dramatically reducing
the odds that you end up in the hospital
or dead I've never hidden that from the
audience I've been very clear
um so I don't know email someone who's
actually doing the things that you say
I'm doing I I'm getting quite bored with
it here's someone who writes in like
five to ten times a week they go by CAD
CAD wrote in and said by the by the way
right away going into their degrees uh
reeks of either dishonesty or
um some some kind of uh low self-esteem
okay
CAD writes in yes I am Highly Educated
with multiple degrees and probably
smarter than some of your audience
members I love how you mock people and
how they talk because it's so
hypocritical you are the one who made me
do a deep dive and become Republican
thank you for that I contribute to
society with my job helping others I
don't read articles and then throw BS
out for an hour and a half with no pitch
a pushback you're not as smart as you
think anyway do you ever watch yourself
on your show you've got to be so smug
because your large teeth and mouse mouth
movements are so gross side Pro Prof
profile blah that's the vomit Emoji blah
who the hell would ever go out with
someone so pompous as yourself they'd
have to constantly stress from being
corrected you're so feminine and your
pronunciation is hysterical it's cringe
many think you progressives are out of
your mind and ruining what was good
about this country go watch yourself you
are one
ugly dude so before you get on a
platform and mock others look in the
mirror what work of yours should be
valued besides mocking people I guess
that's a statement not a question
um you know I used to get upset about
messages like this because someone is it
they're they're criticizing so many
things about me
and then one of the kind of uh
Awakenings I had was
I thought to myself you know I watch
lots of different things
I've never written to anyone that is the
host of any show I watch ever and if I
did
I would be embarrassed to send messages
like this because they're so bizarre and
out there and so then I imagined what
kind of person
would even send a message like this what
must their life be like where they have
either the time or the idea or the
interest of saying I'm going to go over
to my computer or pull out my phone and
write something like this to someone I
don't even know and then I realized how
sad the lives of the trolls must be
and then I stopped worrying about them I
actually kind of just feel bad now and
I've spoken to some other people about
it and and they who do what I do and
they've sort of come to a similar
position and it really is sad it really
is sad what must be going on in
someone's life
to think to write something like that to
someone else anyway let's get into some
of the more substantive stuff Andrew
from Oregon wrote in with an interesting
message he said one effective question
to ask anti-vaxxers hey David long time
Watcher love your work as covet has seen
a recent uptick and it doesn't seem like
it's going away anytime soon the debate
over preventative measures continues to
rage I've found a really effective way
to stump anti-vaxxers is to ask them
what group of experts informs your covet
views
they may point to cherry-pick data
devoid of context or individuals who
share their view but never a collection
of experts there isn't a university a
hospital or scientific body of any sort
they rely on every time it seems to
promote promote provoke a moment of
self-reflection on the veracity of the
source of their information and I find
it's a great Foundation to build from
yeah this is an interesting idea because
often the the science deniers will say
ignore everything all doctors say except
this one radiologist who's commenting
about vaccines despite it being
completely outside his or her area of
expertise and the question is an
interesting one because when you say
what group of experts they often will
say well you really can't trust
immunologists now you have to trust this
one person all the other immunologists
are wrong or you can't really trust
pulmonologists because they mostly are
lying about covid but this one uh
pulmonologist has has gotten outside of
of the bubble it is a good question and
I think only with some people only with
with people who are most open to having
their views
um examined would it would it have an
impact but it is an interesting idea
because it's not about expertise it's
about finding people that already agree
with them and then saying here's who I'm
going to listen to and I've met people
personally during the pandemic who early
in the pandemic said these are the these
are the three people that you can really
trust
during the Pandemic those three people's
views have changed as informed by data
and Science and then the people who used
to go to them say they can't they're not
they're no longer trustworthy here's the
other people I now trust well it's not
that the people are less trustworthy
it's that you you no longer agree with
the things that they're saying and it is
uh it is something I I see quite often
PK wrote in
um sort of a tongue-in-cheek response to
that guy who called in recently and
attacked me for being not that tall
um and PK wrote in about David's height
and weight says Dear David I am five
eight and weigh 165. that obviously
gives me a 15 pound intellectual
advantage over you I'm sorry sir but
that's just the science thank you for
your time yes and obviously this
individual outweighs Me by 15 pounds but
it's 15 pounds of brain matter certainly
I have to make a correction and I'm glad
Catherine from the UK is helping me do
that I wrongly stated the other day
in passing and as a complete joke that
the coleslaw at KFC is vegan
um Catherine wrote in and said hey David
watching the video about bolsonaro in
Florida and was Keen when you mentioned
the coleslaw from KFC being vegan I'm in
the UK where the slaw is not vegan so I
had a look it's not vegan in the U.S
either unfortunately it's vegan in
Canada I understand though perhaps there
is hope for the rest of the world okay
uh yeah I don't know I don't really know
anything about KFC coleslaw I remembered
that producer Pat once told me the KFC
coleslaw was vegan Pat has no
recollection of that so I don't really
know where I got it but I don't go to
KFC and I'm also not vegan so it ended
up being sort of a sort of a moot point
I guess we would say Oliver wrote in
about the phenomenon of they Oliver says
hey David have you noticed that many
especially on the right are increasingly
using the term they to Define political
opposition for example they want to
silence us they want to sexualize
children they are the Elite is this just
a symptom of seemingly populist rhetoric
with those on the other side thrown into
the one basket I.E the elite with no
room for substance or does it boil down
to something else entirely that's Ali
from Scotland I don't think they know
what they mean you know I've had
conversations where they'll they they
I'm doing it too it is an interesting
shorthand
right-wingers who call me let me be
precise Sometimes some right-wingers who
call me will say
they are
not allowing us to investigate the
origins of covid and I'll say who is
they
uh is it Democrats and they'll go well
no it's not really Democrats no is it
the media is the media preventing
anybody from no it's not really the
media is it I don't know like is it
marxists because that's enough an often
used Trope no it's not Mark and then you
see they don't even know who they is so
as a rhetorical technique I do think it
can sometimes be useful to say to those
with whom you are speaking
who is they exactly it's not Biden
it's not Hunter
it's not fouchy it's not uh you know
Anderson Cooper who is it exactly and
some of them are Slicker and they will
be more prepared and they'll say
something like I I say they because it's
the establishment it's no one person but
it's the total atmosphere created by the
oh okay all right but it's a good
question who do you what do you mean by
they I think it is a it's a useful
technique email in info davidpackman.com
and please come on over to the bonus
show you can sign up at joinpakman.com
you can get instant access and it's an
extra show every single day for our
website members you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now at joinpakman.com